[Music]
peter
why would someone not want you to be
alive anymore what are you talking about
code 8227 confirmed subject's closed
[Music]
[Applause]
i know you like ava but she's a
liability
no not her she's best to breathe i
recruited her i trained her she's
talking to the targets
ava i'm good promise you keep your head
down kiddo management will be watching
on this one
you did something bad i wouldn't have
sent me if you had
who was responsible company had nothing
to do with it you don't believe that
duke
you keep breaking protocol i asked you
to marry me and then you just
disappeared for eight years
she's always been duke's favor but she's
a loose kind of uh danger to the
organization
no one's killed i don't tooth her finger
i don't care which
[Music]
i warned you i'm not going to be able to
protect you a second time
[Music]
you need to rescind the kill order you
know i can't do that
this is business
lovely morning for it ava
put security around my family on high
[Music]
alert
[Music]
you